I'd like to take a moment and consider
what you are wearing right now I have a
deep philosophical question for you why
are we not all wearing comfortable
pajamas right now well I'm a
psychologist and not a mind-reader
although many people think that's the
same thing I convey you that your
response is somewhere along the lines of
I am expected to know where PJs in
public or I don't want people to think I
am a slob
either way the fact that we all chose to
wear business casual clothing as opposed
to a favorite pair of sweatpants is not
a Silicon incidence instead it reveals
two defining human characteristics the
first is that we're cognizant of what
other people value like what they will
approve or disapprove of such as not
wearing PJs to these sorts of settings
and two we readily use this information
to guide our behavior unlike many other
species humans are prone to tailor their
behavior in the presence of others to
garner approval we spend valuable time
putting on makeup
choosing the right picture and Instagram
filter and composing ideas that will
undoubtedly change the world in 140
characters or less clearly our concern
with how other people will evaluate us
is a big part of being human despite
this being a big human trait however we
know relatively little about when and
how we come to care about the opinion of
others now this is a big question that
requires many studies the first step to
uncovering this question is to
investigate when in development we
become sensitive to others evaluations I
have spent the past four years at Emory
University investigating how an infant
who has no problem walking around the
grocery store in her onesie develop into
an adult that fears public speaking for
fear of being negatively judged
now this is usually a point when people
ask me how do you investigate this
question exactly
infants can't talk right well if my
husband were up here right now he would
tell you that I interview babies because
he would rather not say that his wives
experiments on children in reality I
design experiments for children usually
in the form of games developmental
psychologist dr. Philippe Rashad and I
designed a game called the robot task to
explore when children would begin to be
sensitive to the evaluation of others
specifically the robot test captures
wind children like adults
strategically modify their behavior when
others are watching to do this we showed
14 to 24 month old infants how to
activate a toy robots and importantly we
there signed a positive value saying wow
isn't that great or a negative value
saying uh-uh
oops oh no after pressing the remote
following this toy demonstration we
invited the infant's to play with the
remote and then either watch them or
turned around and pretended to read a
magazine the idea was that it's like 24
months children are indeed sensitive to
the evaluation of others when their
button-pressing behavior should be
influenced not only by whether or not
they're being watched but also by the
values of the experimenter expressed
towards pressing the remote so for
example we were to expect children to
play with the positive remote
significantly more if they were being
observed then choose to explore the
negative remote once no one was watching
to really capture this phenomenon we did
three variations of the study study one
explored how infants would engage with a
novel toy and there were no values or
instructions provided so we simply
shared infants how to activate the toy
robot but didn't assign any values and
we also didn't tell them that they could
play with their remote providing them
with a really ambiguous situation in
study 2 we incorporated the two values a
positive and a negative and in the last
study we had two experimenters in one
remote one experimenter expressed a
negative value towards pressing the
remote sang-hyuk between moved while the
other experimenters Fresa pasa
value saying yay the toy moved and this
is how the children reacted to these
three different scenarios some study one
it's the ambiguous situation I'm
currently watching the child she doesn't
seem to be too interested in pressing
the remote once I turn around
now she's ready to play currently I'm
not watching the child she's really
focused I turned around she wasn't doing
anything right and study two is the two
remotes one with the positive and one
with a negative value I'm currently
observing the child and the orange
remotes is a negative remote she's just
looking around looking at me hanging out
and I turn around that's what she's
going for I'm not watching the child she
wants the mom to play with it right
take a safer route I turn around he
wasn't doing anything either yeah he
feels awkward everyone knows that side I
glanced right study three the two
experimenters one remote the
experimenter that reacted negatively
towards pressing the remotes watching
the child right now she feels a little
awkward doesn't know what to do relying
on mom and then she's going to turn
around so that the experimenter that
expressed a positive response is
watching coast is clear now she's ready
to play so as the data suggests we found
that childrens button-pressing behavior
was indeed influenced by the values and
the instructions of the experimenter
because of study one children did not
know what would be positively or
negatively evaluated they tended to take
the safest route and wait until I turned
to my back to press the remote children
and study to chose to press the positive
remote significantly more when I was
watching but then once I turned to my
back the immediately took
the negative remote and started playing
with it importantly in the control study
where we removed the different values of
the remotes so we simply said oh wow
after pressing either of the remotes
children's button pressing behavior no
longer differed across conditions
suggesting that it were it was really
the values that we gave the two remotes
that drove the behavior in the previous
study last but not least children in
study 3 chose to press a remote
significantly more when the experimenter
that expressed a positive value is
watching are supposed to be experimental
that expressed a negative value not
coincidentally it is also around this
age the children begin to show
embarrassment in situations that might
elicit a negative evaluation such as
looking at themselves in the mirror and
noticing a mark on their nose the
equivalent of finding spinach in your
teeth for adults so what can we say
based on these findings besides the fact
that babies are actually really really
sneaky from very early on children like
adults are sensitive to the values that
we place on objects and behaviors and
importantly they use these values to
guide their behavior whether we are
aware of it or not we're constantly
communicating values to those around us
now I don't mean values like be kind or
don't steal although those are certainly
values I mean that we are constantly
showing others specifically our children
what is likeable valuable and
praiseworthy and what is not and a lot
of the times we actually do this without
even noticing it psychologists study
behavior to explore the contents of the
mind because their behavior often
reflects our beliefs our values and our
desires here in Atlanta we all believe
the same thing the coke is madder than
Pepsi
now this may have to do with the facts
that Coke was invented in Atlanta but
regardless this belief is expressed in
the fact that most people will choose to
drink Coke in the same way we're
communicating a value when we mostly
compliment girls for their pretty hair
or their pretty dress but boys for their
intelligence or when we choose to offer
candy as opposed to nutritious food as a
reward for good behavior adults and
children are incredibly effective at
picking out values from these subtle
behaviors and in turn this up this ends
up shaping their own behavior the
research I have shared with you today
suggests that this ability emerges very
early in development before we can even
utter a complete sentence or even
potty-trained and it becomes an integral
part of who we grow up to be so before I
go I'd like to invite you to contemplate
on the values that we broadcast in
day-to-day interactions and how these
values might be shaping the behavior of
those around you
for example what values being
broadcasted when we spend more time
smiling on her phone than smiling with
other people
likewise consider how your own behavior
has been shaped by those around you and
ways you might not have considered
before to go back to our simple
illustration do you really prefer Coke
or Pepsi or was this preference simply
driven by what others around you valued
parents and teachers certainly have the
privilege to shape children's behavior
but it is important to remember but
through the values we convey in simple
day-to-day interactions we all have the
power to shape the behavior of those
around us thank you
[Applause]